Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. A war began for no wise purpose, carried on with a strange mixture of rashness and timidity, brought to a close after suffering and disaster, without much glory attached either to the government which directed or the great body of troops which waged it. Not one benefit, political or military, has been acquired with this war. Our eventual evacuation of the country resembled the retreat of an army defeated. That was not a newspaper report on this week's calamitous American evacuation of Kabul,
感谢收听《历史的 rest is history》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这场战争的发动毫无明智目的，进行时充满了鲁莽与怯懦的奇异混合，在一片苦难与灾难之后草草收场，无论是指挥这场战争的政府，还是发动这场战争的主力部队，都没有带来多少荣耀。在这场战争中，没有获得哪怕一个政治或军事上的利益。我们最终撤出该国，活像一支战败的军队。这不是对本周美国灾难性撤离喀布尔的新闻报道，
but the report on an earlier Western engagement in Afghanistan. The first Anglo-Afghan war, and it was the words of the Reverend George Gleig, who wrote the first account of that war in 1843. And Dominic, some eerie parallels there, aren't there? Yeah, it's hard to resist the parallels. So that's one of the most famous military disasters in British history. It's our first great encounter with Afghanistan. Some listeners will know it as the stuff of the very first Flashman book. That's how I first encountered it. And I think other listeners, Tom, may know the painting. I don't know if you know the painting.
而是关于早期西方介入阿富汗的报道。第一次英阿战争，这是乔治·格莱格（George Gleig）牧师的话，他在1843年写下了关于那场战争的第一份记录。多米尼克，那里有惊人的相似之处，对吧？是的，这些相似之处很难不让人联想起。所以这是英国历史上最著名的军事灾难之一。这是我们与阿富汗的第一次重大接触。一些听众会知道它是《弗莱什曼》系列第一本书的题材。这也是我最初接触到它的方式。我想其他听众，汤姆，可能知道那幅画。我不知道你知不知道那幅画。
I bet you do. By Elizabeth Butler called Remnants of an Army, where the last guy, the one survivor. Dr. Bryden. Dr. William Bryden. He's sort of on his horse or mule or whatever it is in the past. And he's the only one survivor. Dr. Bryden. Dr. William Bryden. He's sort of on his horse or mule or whatever it is in the past. And he's the sort of, he's the only one left. You know, nearly 20,000 men have been,
我敢打赌你知道。伊丽莎白·巴特勒（Elizabeth Butler）画的，名叫《军队的残余》（Remnants of an Army），画中最后那个人，唯一的幸存者。布莱顿医生。威廉·布莱顿医生。他有点骑在马上、骡子或诸如此类的东西上，在过去。他是某种意义上的，只剩下他一个人了。你知道，将近两万名男子被，
women and children have been killed. Him and Flashman, of course. What's Flashman, of course. Flashman is the other survivor. But of course, this is the, this is the image of Afghanistan that is so current in the newspapers at the moment, the graveyard of empires. So the British tried and failed, supposedly, this is the claim, the British
妇女和儿童被杀害。当然还有他和弗莱什曼。什么是弗莱什曼，当然。弗莱什曼是另一个幸存者。但当然，这就是目前报纸上经常出现的阿富汗形象，帝国的坟墓。所以英国人尝试并失败了，据称，这就是这种说法，英国人
tried and failed, the Soviet Union tried and failed, and now the United States has tried and failed as well. Okay, well, I think there is really only one person to get on to talk to us about the first Afghan war. And that is Willie Dalrymple, who was an earlier guest talking about his book, The Anarchy on the East India Company, which in a way is a kind of the prequel to the events we're going to discuss today. He comes with a slight health warning,
尝试并失败了，苏联尝试并失败了，现在美国也尝试并失败了。好吧，我认为真的只有一个人能来跟我们谈谈第一次阿富汗战争。那就是威利·达尔林普尔（Willie Dalrymple），他之前曾作为嘉宾谈论过他的书《东印度公司的无政府状态》（The Anarchy on the East India Company），从某种意义上说，这可以说是我们今天要讨论的事件的前传。他带有一个小小的健康警告，
though, doesn't he, Tom? Because he is the holder of the Rest Is History all-time record for speaking uninterrupted. He is. Without interventions from us, which I think, so I think he spoke for basically an hour and we said hello and goodbye. Well, somebody commented on Twitter that he was like Fenton, the notorious dog that went chasing deer in Richmond Park.
对吧，汤姆？因为他是《历史的 rest is history》有史以来连续发言不被打断的纪录保持者。他确实是。在我们没有插话的情况下，我想，所以他基本上讲了一个小时，而我们只说了hello和goodbye。嗯，有人在推特上评论说他就像芬顿（Fenton），那个在里士满公园追逐鹿的臭名昭著的狗。
And there was the hapless man running after him shouting Fenton, Fenton. And that's what we were like. So it's very exciting to have Willie back on the show. about this, The Return of a King, which is part of the Company Quartet, this collection of four volumes about the East India Company in India, which is available now. So I hope I've made my dues there. So Fenton. You can shout Fenton at any point if you want me to stand to leash. Okay, I'm going to throw you a stick here. The first Afghan war, how does it begin? So this is rather a long story. So one evening in 1837, a man who you're, I'm sure, very familiar with,
还有一个倒霉的家伙跟在后面大喊芬顿，芬顿。我们当时就像那样。所以威利能再次来到节目中真是太令人兴奋了。关于这个，《重返国王》（The Return of a King），这是公司四部曲的一部分，这个关于印度东印度公司的四卷集现在已经出版了。所以我希望我在那里尽到责任了。所以是芬顿。如果你想让我戴上狗链，随时可以大喊芬顿。好吧，我要给你扔根棍子。第一次阿富汗战争，它是怎么开始的？所以这是一个相当长的故事。所以1837年的一个晚上，有一个人你，我确信，非常熟悉，
George Rawlinson, who's famous for translating the Behistun inscription, who's this orientalist who'd been based in Persia as part of the East India Company mission to try and get cozy with Persia and to turn them against Russia, who were East India Company's great rivals. And in the background to this is that over the previous hundred years, at the same time as the East India Company was expanding out of Calcutta to take over all of India and then marching towards the Himalayas, same time as this is happening, in Russia, the Russians are moving south at a rate of 100 miles every decade. And by the 1840s have reached what was called the Orenburg Line, which is just north of the great caravan cities of Kiva, Bokhara, Tashkent, which, as we know now, will fall to Russia in the 1880s and 1890s and in a later phase of the period. But at this point in 1840, the East India Company has now occupied
乔治·罗林森（George Rawlinson），他因翻译贝希ستون铭文而闻名，这位东方学者曾驻扎在波斯，作为东印度公司使团的一部分，试图与波斯套近乎，并让他们反抗东印度公司的死敌俄国。而这背后的背景是，在过去的的一百年里，正当东印度公司从加尔各答扩张以接管整个印度然后向喜马拉雅山进军的同时，与此同时，在俄国，俄国人正以每十年100英里的速度向南移动。到了19世纪40年代，他们已经到达了所谓的奥伦堡线（Orenburg Line），该线就在希瓦、布哈拉、塔什干这些伟大商队城市的正北方，正如我们现在所知，这些城市将在19世纪80年代和90年代以及该时期的后一阶段落入俄国手中。但此时在1840年，东印度公司现已占领了
all of India, South Sutledge, the Russians are at the Orenberg Line and everyone is eyeing the territory, the shrinking space in between these two expanding empires. And so what George Rawlinson sees one early dawn in 1837 is very important. He's writing from Beh behist where he's been literally in the middle of translating this inscription been uh built a scaffold to take all the cuneiform down and so this is the inscription left by darius the great back in the late 6th century bc and this is kind of the rosetta stone of uh of the persian because it also has aramaic and that allowed uh the translation to uh to be made and roland has Aramaic and it allowed the translation to be made.
整个印度，萨特累季河以南，俄国人已经在奥伦堡线上，每个人都在盯着这片领土，盯着这两个不断扩张的帝国之间不断缩小的空间。因此，乔治·罗林森在1837年某个清晨所看到的东西非常重要。他正在贝希斯顿（Behistun）写作，他一直在那里字面意义上地翻译这个铭文，搭建了一个脚手架来把所有的楔形文字拓下来，所以这是大流士大帝在公元前6世纪末留下的铭文，这可以说是波斯语的罗塞塔石碑，因为它也有阿拉姆语，这使得翻译得以完成，罗林森阿拉姆语，并且它允许翻译得以完成。
And Rawlinson, who's literally been working on this the previous six months in all his spare time, has now been summoned back to work, so to speak, from this Orientalist sabbatical on the Bayeuston inscription and is riding towards the Persian border city of Meshet where the new Shah is about to try and invade the principality just over the border of his territory, which is Herat, previously a great center of Persianate culture for many centuries, but now independent of the Qajar kings of
罗林森字面意义上在过去的六个月里利用所有的空闲时间一直在研究这个，现在被召回工作，可以说，从他对贝希斯顿铭文的东方学者休假中被召回，正骑马前往波斯边境城市马什哈德（Meshed），新沙阿正准备试图入侵他领土边境刚过去的领地，也就是赫拉特（Herat），这里以前几个世纪是波斯文化的一个伟大中心，但现在独立于波斯的卡扎尔（Qajar）国王。
Persia. And there are Russian military advisors working for Persians and the East India Company are very unhappy about this. So Rawlinson's been sent off to observe the start of this campaign. And he's been riding from Western Persia because a war is breaking out. The normal post-horse system isn't working in the Karabakhs' right. And he can't get his mount exchanged. So he's exhausted, his horse is exhausted. And at some point, just as he's heading towards Meshed, he actually falls asleep in the saddle.
并且有为波斯人工作的俄国军事顾问，东印度公司对此非常不满。所以罗林森被派去观察这场战役的开始。他一直从波斯西部骑马过来，因为一场战争正在爆发。正常的驿马系统在卡拉巴赫（Karabakhs）运行不正常。而且他无法更换坐骑。所以他筋疲力尽，他的马也筋疲力尽。在某个时刻，就在他朝着马什哈德前进时，他实际上在马鞍上睡着了。
It's a long time since I've ridden seriously and I don't know how long he'll probably stay asleep in a saddle without falling off. But when the moment comes that he does sort of nearly slip off the saddle in his sleep and wakes up, he realises that his horse has wandered off the road and he's lost in these very dangerous borderlands. Now, even today, this is a place where opium smugglers work the heroin trade between Iran and Afghanistan. It's a place that has always been what we call in Scotland debatable land.
我已经很久没有认真骑过马了，我不知道他在马鞍上不掉下来能睡多久。但当他真的在睡梦中差点从马鞍上滑落并醒来的那一刻，他意识到他的马已经偏离了道路，他在这些非常危险的边境地区迷路了。现在，即使在今天，这也是一个鸦片走私者从事伊朗和阿富汗之间海洛因贸易的地方。这是一个一直是我们在苏格兰所说的争议之地的地方。
It's the border of the territory that you just do not want to get lost in at any time, particularly in a war, particularly at this moment. So Rollins is quite frightened and he wanders around in the dark, not quite sure what to do. He's not on a road, doesn't know where he is. And then dawn breaks over the Koh-i-Shah Jahan mountain and he begins to orientate himself. You can see a valley. He's heading towards it when he sees a cloud of dust coming towards him. And he knows what it is. There's clearly a large body of men heading towards him on horseback. So he does what any of us would do in this situation. He dismounts. He ties up his horse in a little overhang of rock and goes belly down to see what's coming.
这是你绝对不想在任何时候迷路的领土边界，特别是在战争中，特别是在这个时刻。所以罗林森相当害怕，他在黑暗中徘徊，不太清楚该做什么。他不在路上，不知道自己在哪里。然后黎明破晓，照在沙贾汉山（Koh-i-Shah Jahan）上，他开始辨别方向。他可以看到一个山谷。正当他朝它走去时，他看到一团尘土向他滚来。他知道那是什么。显然有一大群人骑着马朝他走来。所以他做了我们任何人在这种情况下都会做的事。他下马了。他在一个岩石突出的地方拴好马，趴在肚子上查看有什么东西过来。
So it's kind of like we have the Wild West. This is the Wild East. This is the Wild East. And of course, because this has to be a movie at some point, Rawlinson is, as well as a prize-winning Persianate orientalist, he's also a secret service agent working for British intelligence, inevitably speaking. And he's in touch with the British spymaster Claude Wade, who's based on the Afghan border, and also Pottinger, who's based in Gujarat. These are the two East India Company spymasters collating information in Central Asia and Afghanistan. The whole ring of spies, of carpet sellers and so on.
所以这有点像我们有美国西部。这是荒野东方。这是荒野东方。当然，因为这在某个时候必须拍成电影，罗林森除了是一位获奖的波斯语东方学者外，不可避免地说，他还是一个为英国情报机构工作的秘密特工。并且他与驻扎在阿富汗边境的英国间谍头子克劳德·韦德（Claude Wade）保持着联系，还有驻扎在古吉拉特邦的波廷杰（Pottinger）。这两个是东印度公司在在中亚和阿富汗搜集信息的间谍头子。整个间谍网，地毯商等等。
The great game. The great game. This is the very, this in a sense is where it begins. It's almost the moment it begins. There's a few spy networks, but there's actually been no action until this moment. And Rawlinson looks up and he sees these horsemen resolve in front of his eyes into the thing that every East India company intelligence officer had been predicting but has never had the evidence for. It is a party of Cossacks in full uniform with a Russian flag flying, heading over the border from Persia into Afghanistan and there's a considerable number of them and Rawlinson then follows them rather bravely and having sort of shadowed them less successfully than he realizes he actually stumbles across them making a samovar of tea in a gully somewhere, just as dawn is coming up.
大博弈。大博弈。这正是，从某种意义上说，这就是它开始的地方。这几乎是它开始的时刻。有一些间谍网络，但直到这一刻实际上还没有发生行动。罗林森抬起头，他看到这些骑马者在他眼前变成了每个东印度公司情报官员一直在预测但从未掌握证据的东西。这是一队穿着全套制服、飘扬着俄国国旗的哥萨克人，正从波斯越过边境进入阿富汗，而且数量相当多，罗林森随后相当勇敢地尾随着他们，在某种程度上对他们进行了跟踪，但他意识到的程度还不够，实际上他无意中撞见他们在某个沟壑里用萨摩瓦尔（samovar）煮茶，正值黎明破产之际。
And in charge is a multilingual, his direct parallel on the Russian side, who is a man called Ivan Vickovich. Now, he doesn't know this, but Vickovich is in fact a Polish Catholic who'd been sent off into exile by the Russians for writing anti-Russian messages on his blackboard in Poland in age 14. He's only one of his school friends to survive the exile where they've been put into hard labour on the steppe and he's learnt Kazakh and all sorts of Persian and Arabic, exactly like Wallis and Herz, And these two men meet each other brewing up tea in the borderlands of Persia and Afghanistan. And they both pretend
而负责人是一个通晓多国语言的人，他在俄国方面的直接对应人物，是一个名叫伊万·维科维奇（Ivan Vickovich）的人。现在，他不知道这一点，但维科维奇实际上是一个波兰天主教徒，由于14岁时在波兰的黑板上写反俄标语而被俄国人流放。他是经历流放后幸存下来的唯一一个同学，他们在草原上被投入苦哈劳动，他学会了哈萨克语和各种波斯语和阿拉伯语，就像沃利斯和赫尔茨一样，这两个人在波斯和阿富汗的边境地区相遇并煮茶。他们俩都假装
not to be what they are. They're both playing around. I think they end up speaking in French to each other, but they try, Rawlinson tries Chagatay Turkish. As you do. As well as Persian and everything else. And Rawlinson, sorry, Mikvich has all these like and realizes in a sense who he's speaking to, although he doesn't know the name of the man. And anyway,
不是他们本来的样子。他们都在演戏。我想他们最后用法语交谈，但他们尝试，罗林森尝试了查加台突尔其语。就像你做的那样。以及波斯语和所有其他语言。罗林森，对不起，米克维奇有所有这些，并且从某种意义上意识到他正在跟谁说话，尽管他不知道那个人的名字。无论如何，
Rawlinson then turns his horse around. He goes straight back to Tehran, although he's been on the road already for whatever it is, a week. And a camel messenger is sent off to the Gulf. Steamships cross to Egypt. The Telegraph, which has got as far, I think, as Sue is at this point,
罗林森随后调转马头。他直接回到了德黑兰，尽管他在路上已经待了无论是一个星期。一个骆驼信使被派往海湾。汽船穿过埃及。电报，我想此时已经通到了苏伊士，
taps out the first Morse code, which crosses to Downing Street. And some chap runs up the steps of the Foreign Office and says the Russians have gone into Afghanistan. And so, Willie, tell us a bit about Afghanistan at this point. So this is a sort of borderland, right? I mean, there are local rulers, but it's a pretty wild place. Am I right? various points in its history, Afghanistan has been the center of many great empires. The Kushans, for example, ruled an empire which straddled most of the Stans, Afghanistan, and northern India. It's not true that Afghanistan has always been this sort of graveyard of empires. The Mughals had it as a very successful summer capital. When we think of Mughal summer capital, we tend to
敲击出第一条莫尔斯电码，传到了唐宁街。某个家伙跑上外交部的台阶说俄国人已经进入了阿富汗。所以，威利，跟我们讲讲此时的阿富汗。所以这是一个某种边境地区，对吧？我的意思是，有地方统治者，但这是一个相当荒凉的地方。我说的对吗？在其历史上的不同时期，阿富汗曾是许多伟大帝国的中心。例如，贵霜人统治过一个横跨大部分“斯坦”地区、阿富汗和印度北部的帝国。阿富汗一直是这种帝国坟墓的说法是不真实的。莫卧儿人把它当作一个非常成功的避暑之都。当我们想到莫卧儿帝国的避暑之都时，我们倾向于
think of Kashmir, because it's within India, and it's part of the same world. But in actual fact, Shah Jahan and Jahangir went as often to Kabul and played in the gardens there as they did to Kashmir. But the last great moment of Central Asian culture has been 200 years earlier with Herat in the 16th century, which Robert Byron described as the Oriental Medici. You have some of the greatest miniature painters. You have some great universities of the Islamic world there. But the whole place has been losing its centrality as a center of culture for a while. There's a revival under a man called Ahmad Shah Durrani, who was one of the generals of Nadia Shah.
想到克什米尔，因为它在印度境内，并且是同一个世界的一部分。但事实上，沙贾汉和贾汉吉尔去喀布尔的次数和他们在那里花园里游玩的次数一样多，就像他们去克什米尔一样。但中亚文化的最后一个伟大时刻是200年前16世纪的赫拉特，罗伯特·拜伦（Robert Byron）将其描述为东方美第奇。你有一些最伟大的微型画家。你在那里拥有伊斯兰世界的一些伟大大学。但这个地方作为文化中心的中心地位已经失去了一段时间。在纳迪尔沙阿（Nadia Shah）的一位将领艾哈迈德·沙阿·杜兰尼（Ahmad Shah Durrani）的领导下，这里经历了一次复兴。
And when Nadia Shah is assassinated, Ahmad Shah Durrani takes the Koh-i-Noor and basically uses it as the capital to found a new state, Afghanistan. And he creates an empire in the 1740s, which is only a century before the moment we're talking about, which gobbles up a chunk of Safavid Persia, a chunk of the Uzbek Empire, and a chunk of Mughal India, and creates for the first time an empire centered on Kabul, full of Afghans and the English, although the word Afghanistan is never used.
而当纳迪尔沙阿被暗杀时，艾哈迈德·沙阿·杜兰尼拿走了光之山钻石，基本上以它为首都建立了一个新国家阿富汗。他在18世纪40年代建立了一个帝国，这距离我们现在谈论的时刻只有一个世纪，它吞并了一块萨法维波斯领土、一块乌兹别克帝国领土和一块莫卧儿印度领土，并在历史上第一次创建了一个以喀布尔为中心、到处都是阿富汗人和英国人的帝国，尽管“阿富汗”这个词从未被使用过。
The kingdom of Kabul is the political phrase. It is. People do talk about for the first time Afghans. And so this is the beginning, in a sense, of the modern Afghan state. And its borders are more or less those of Afghanistan by default, because the Persians are where Persia is. Mobile India has now sort of ended with the Sikh Empire and the Punjab and the Uzbeks have steadied at the oxen. So you have this space in between, of course, the title of Rory Stewart's book, which becomes Afghanistan. And so are they consciously playing, I mean, are they consciously playing off the Russians and the British? Because they're conscious of these two empires either side. And half the story of it, which again, you know, has echoes today, is that the British fear of Russia creates the very nightmare that they fear. Because what happens is that following the sighting of Vitkovich by Rawlinson, this meeting in the desert, spies are sent off into Central Asia.
喀布尔王国是政治上的说法。确实如此。人们第一次谈论阿富汗人。所以从某种意义上说，这是现代阿富汗国家的开始。它的边界差不多就是阿富汗默认的边界，因为波斯人在波斯所在的地方。莫卧儿印度现在某种程度上已经随着锡克帝国和旁遮普而结束了，乌兹别克斯坦人在阿姆河（Oxus）稳定下来。所以你有了中间的空间，当然，罗里·斯图尔特（Rory Stewart）的书名，后来成为了阿富汗。那么他们是有意在，我的意思是，他们是有意在俄国人和英国人之间进行平衡吗？因为他们意识到了这两侧的帝国？其中的一半故事，再次，你知道，在今天也有回响，那就是英国对俄国的恐惧制造了他们所恐惧的噩梦。因为发生的事情是，在罗林森发现维科维奇之后，在沙漠中的这次会面，间谍被派往中亚。
One of these is Alexander Burns, who's also a great showman and a travel writer. And Alexander Burns has this wonderful moment when he travels up the Indus on a raft. And they have to have an excuse to get permission to go up the Indus. So what they know is that Ranjit Singh, the Sikh ruler of Lahore, loves horses. They decide to present him with four enormous English cart horses. And then just to add to the whole thing,
其中之一是亚历山大·伯恩斯（Alexander Burns），他也是一个伟大的表演者和旅行作家。亚历山大·伯恩斯有一个美妙的时刻，他乘木筏沿印度河逆流而上。他们必须有一个借口来获得沿印度河而上的许可。所以他们知道拉贾吉·辛格（Ranjit Singh），拉合尔的锡克统治者，喜欢马。他们决定送给他四匹巨大的英国重型挽马。然后为了增加整体的效果，
they decide they're going to take an old carriage that used to belong to the Lord Mayor of London. And they stuff it full of geographers from the Admiralty who are busy taking soundings of the depth of the Indus and the flow charts and all the rest of it. So this really quite professional spying expedition is heading up the Indus on a raft, being popped at shots being popped at it by local
他们决定带一辆以前属于伦敦市长的旧马车。他们往里面塞满了来自海军部的地理学家，他们正忙着测定印度河的深度、流量图以及其他所有东西。所以这个非常专业的间谍探险队乘木筏沿印度河逆流而上，遭到当地部落成员的零星射击，伯恩斯坐在伦敦市长马车和四匹格格不入的英国重挽马旁边。这怎么还没拍成电影？太棒了。而伯恩斯，快进来说，
tribesmen, with Burns sitting beside the Lord Mayor of London's coach and four English dray horses who've been rather out of place. How has this not been made into a film? Wonderful. And Burns, to fast forward,
不仅向他的金主提供了整套间谍情报材料，因为他是个间谍，而且他还以大地理学家为掩护。他写了一本关于他去布哈拉旅行的三卷本记述，成为了一本畅销书。他受到了维多利亚女王的接见，女王认为他非常迷人。他不仅获得了伦敦皇家地理学会的金奖，还获得了法国的同等奖项。他的书被翻译成法语，当然，俄国人也读了它。而那些在布哈拉没有间谍的俄国人随后派维科维奇去侦察。而维科维奇成功地摧毁了亚历山大·伯恩斯建立的间谍网络，他在
not only presents a whole body of espionage material to his paymaster, because he is a spy, but he also, as his cover, is the great geographer. And he writes a three volume account of his travels to Bacara, which becomes a bestseller. He's received by Queen Victoria, who thinks he's very charming. He gets not only the gold medal of the Royal Geographical Society in London, but he also gets its French equivalent. His book is translated into French and, of course, the Russians read it. And the Russians who do not have spies in Bukharov then send Vikovich to spy it out. And Vikovich successfully rolls up Alexander Byrne's espionage network uh that he's set up uh in
布哈拉建立的网络——我的意思是，这其实不过是几个地毯商，但每个人都已经知道他们为英国工作——不过关键是不要写书，关键是不要告诉所有人你在做什么，我的意思是，无论如何这很疯狂。嗯，所以英国人成功地在俄国人中间制造了一种偏执。我的意思是，有一种非常普遍的恐惧，即俄国人确实在向南移动。但是不，俄国人并没有专门把目光投向阿富汗。当然直到这一点，除了短暂的时刻，又一次，另一个精彩的粗糙故事。蒂尔西特（Tilsit），当俄国沙皇亚历山大和拿破仑在一艘驳船上会面并计划在1810年一起进攻印度时？1812年是撤退。所以1809年，1812年，《战争与和平》开篇于蒂尔西特之前。
bucaro i mean so it's actually no more than a couple of carpet dealers but already everyone knows they're working british but basically the key is don't write a book the keys don't tell everyone what you're doing i mean it's mad anyway um so so the british managed to create a paranoia in the Russians. I mean, there is a very generalised fear that the Russians definitely are moving south. But no, the Russians do not specifically have their eyes on Afghanistan. And certainly up to this point, other than a brief moment when, again, another wonderful rough story. of Tilsit, when Alexander the Tsar of Russia and Napoleon meet on a barge and plan to abate India together in 1810? 1812 is the retreat. So 1809, 1812, War and Peace opens with Before
那是《战争与和平》的第一卷。今天我们总是把它读作《战争与和平》，但它实际上是三卷，在蒂尔西特之前。故事再次据称是这样，但我不知道是否属实，木筏底下有一个英国间谍。我希望这是真的。彼得·霍普克（Peter Hopkirk）在他的书中有这个，其他人也胡乱记下过，但我确实想相信它。而且确实有拿破仑构思的非常遥远且异想天开的入侵印度的计划，但那是俄国唯一一次真正考虑入侵印度，那是在拿破仑旁边，在俄国法兰西联盟的这个短暂时刻，因此，尽管如此，在伦敦，特别是
Tilsit. That's book one of War and Peace. Today we always read it as War and Peace, but it's actually three volumes, Before Tilted. And the story goes again allegedly but I don't know whether it's true that there is a British spy under the raft. I hope it's true. Peter Hopkirk has this in his book, other people have scribbled it but I certainly want to believe it. And definitely there are plans that Napoleon hatches very far-fetched and bonkers to invade India but that's the only time that russia has actually thought of invading india uh and that was alongside napoleon in this brief moment of of russian french union and uh so nonetheless in london particularly
在一个叫埃伦伯勒勋爵（Lord Ellenborough）的人手下，他有点像是，我不知道今天政坛上的对应人物是谁，也许是迈克尔·戈夫（Michael Gove）处于他某种伊斯兰教狂热中。他说，我们正处于来自俄国熊的巨大危险之中。当维科维奇越境进入俄国的消息传来时，伯恩斯被派往喀布尔执行任务，试图将多斯特·穆罕默德（Dost Mohammed）拉入英国势力范围。那么谁是多斯特·穆罕默德？让我打断你一下。多斯特·穆罕默德是刚刚推翻艾哈迈德·沙阿·杜兰尼孙子（名叫沙阿·苏贾，Shah Shuja）的人。现在，沙阿·苏贾流亡到英属印度，在那里他被作为英国的傀儡保留下来，如果英国人愿意，他们可以把他放回去。
under somebody called lord ellenborough who is the sort of um i don't know who the equivalent in politics is today maybe michael gove on one of his more Islamist brats. He says, we are in great danger from the Russian bear. And when the news comes that Vicovich has crossed into Russia, Burns is sent on a mission to Kabul to try and pull Das Mohammed into the British sphere. So who's Das Mohammed? Let me interrupt you. Das Mohamed is the man who has just overthrown Ahmad Shah Durrani's grandson, who is called Shah Shuja. Now, Shah Shuja goes off into exile in British India, where he's been kept in reserve
他的敌人多斯特·穆罕默德现在正统治着阿富汗。威利，这是真的吗，我可以打断你吗？他们愿意。多斯特·穆罕默德，他的敌人，现在正在统治阿富汗。这是真的吗，威利，我可以打断你吗？我读到多斯特·穆罕默德有16个妻子、27个儿子和25个女儿，这是真的吗？这绝对可能是真的，因为他本人绝对是他父亲的第18个儿子。哇，那是一个大家庭聚会。正如你所想象的，当你有17个哥哥时，要成为统治继承人。是的，你必须是。
as a British puppet that the British can put back if they want to. Das Mohamed, his enemy, is now running Afghanistan. And is it true, Willie, can I interrupt you they want to. Dost Muhammad, his enemy, is now running Afghanistan. And is it true, Willie, can I interrupt you? Is it true, I read, that Dost Muhammad had 16 wives, 27 sons and 25 daughters? It certainly could be true because he himself is definitely the 18th son of his father. Wow, that's a big family gathering. And as you can imagine, to get to be the ruling heir when you have 17 elder brothers. Yeah, you've got to be.
毫无疑问的冷酷无情。无论如何，多斯特·穆罕默德对英国人实际上没有任何恶意，对俄国人也没有什么特殊的喜爱。伯恩斯非常清楚地指出，完全没有必要推翻多斯特·穆罕默德。我们可以非常容易地把他拉入我们的网和我们的联盟中。但到了这个时候，
No uncertain ruthlessness. Anyway, Das Mohammed actually has no ill feeling towards the British at all or any particular fondness for the Russians. And Burns says very clearly that there's absolutely no need to topple Das Mohammed. We can pull him into our net and into our alliances very easily. But by this time,
伯恩斯是印度最受恨的人，因为他刚刚来到，获得了所有的荣耀，见到了维多利亚女王，拿到了两枚金奖牌。而他在阿富汗边境工作的所有上司都绝对恨他。他们对这个迷人年轻人的成功嫉妒得发绿。而且还有很多关于他一直在和喀布尔的女人睡觉等等诸如此类的故事。
Burns is the most hated man in India because he has just come, got all the glory, met Queen Victoria, got the two gold medals. And all his superiors who've been working on the Afghan frontier absolutely hate him. They are green with jealousy at the success of this glamorous young man. And there's also quite a lot of stories that he's been sleeping with the women of Kabul and all this sort of stuff.
所以两个间谍头子，波廷杰和韦德，尽其所能地贬低伯恩斯从喀布尔发出的所有信息。最后，这是一个非常糟糕的决定，即必须罢免多斯特·穆罕默德。他并不需要。而在此时，东印度公司甚至没有与阿富汗接壤。他们必须穿过锡克旁遮普。旁遮普雄狮兰吉特·辛格拥有一支由前拿破仑将军训练的极其美妙的军队。他拥有极好的大农炮，任何在伦敦的人都可以看到，
So the two spy chiefs, Pottinger and Waite, do their best to rubbish everything that Burns is sending from Kabul. And in the end, a very bad decision that Dost Muhammad needs to be removed. He doesn't. And at this point, the East India Company doesn't even have a border with Afghanistan. They have to go through the Sikh Punjab. Ranjit Singh, the Lion of the Punjab, has an incredibly wonderful army trained up by ex-Napoleonic generals. He has fantastic cannon, which anyone who's in London can see
因为它们现在排列在切尔西医院（Chelsea Hospital）的草坪上。如果你去切尔西，你可以看到所有这些带兰吉特·辛格徽章的尖端锡克大农炮。大军出发了。2万名男子离开
because they're now lined up on the lawns of Chelsea Hospital. If you go into Chelsea, you can see all these fantastic state-of-the-art Sikh cannon with all Ranjit Singh's insignia on them. And the army sets off. 20,000 men leave
旁遮普的费罗兹普尔（Ferozpur）。与他们同行的还有这些奇妙的随营家属。一位将军有26头骆驼来运送他的装备和一个酒吧。还有
Ferozpur in the Punjab. And with them are this fantastic camp followers. One general has 26 camels to carry his kit and a bar. There are
五头骆驼专门用来运送军队的雪茄供应。一头骆驼什么也没运。五头骆驼运雪茄？这可能吗？还有一头骆驼完全用来为军官运送古龙水。这让你感到
five camels dedicated only to bringing the army's supply of cheroots. One camel carries nothing. Five camels with cheroots? Is that possible? And one camel is entirely carrying eau de cologne for the officers. Makes you proud
身为英国人而自豪。最棒的是，他们当然还带了他们的猎狐犬。当然。这支荒唐的军队穿过旁遮普进军，因为那里土地肥沃可爱，但随后进入了俾路支沙漠
to be British. Best of all, they've also, of course, brought their foxhounds. Of course. And the ridiculous army marches off through the Punjab, which is perfectly because it's fertile and lovely, but then into the Baluchi desert
盛夏时节。他们本应在冬天离开，他们都穿着冬装。但由于兰吉特·辛格一直在拼命拖延给予他们穿过旁遮普的许可，这是对的，因为他知道一旦他们把东印度公司置于他的南北两侧，他就死定了。所以他们最终在盛夏穿过了俾路支沙漠，气温达到50度，他们像苍蝇一样倒下。一半的猎狐犬死了。有各种各样的……
in the middle of summer. They're meant to leave in winter and they've all left in winter outfits. But because Rajat Singh has been frantically dragging his feet on giving them permission, quite rightly, to cross the Punjab, because he knows that the minute they put the East India Company north
不知怎的，随军的赛尔夫人（Lady Sale）设法把她的三角钢琴弄了过去。赛尔夫人雇了多少头骆驼才把它弄上去的？不管怎样。所以这个荒谬的……那么赛尔夫人为什么要走？
and south of him, he's dead. So they end up crossing the Baluchi desert in the middle of high summer, temperatures reaching 50 degrees, and they drop like flies. Half the foxhounds die. There are all sorts of...
威利，赛尔夫人为什么要走？他们有古龙水，他们有鞋子。他们唯一没有的是地图。对吧。她为什么要走？汤姆，这是一个好问题。赛尔夫人为什么要走，她为什么要带……我的意思是，带钢琴太疯狂了。那简直是精神错乱才随身带一架钢琴。嗯，你得去问赛尔夫人。但她去只是为了好玩。她带三角钢琴是因为她想弹。赛尔夫人去是为了好玩，为了好玩。她带三角钢琴是因为她想弹。赛尔夫人去是为了好玩，为了刺激。不，不，她嫁给了一直在战斗的鲍勃·赛尔（Fighting Bob Sale），他是……好吧，对，对。所以她是一个军人的妻子。
Somehow, Lady Sail, who's with the army, manages to get her grand piano through. How many camels have been employed by Lady Sail to get it up? Anyway. So this ridiculous... So why is Lady Sail going?
所以没有……我想，实际上，公平地说，赛尔夫人几个月后才跟进。她实际上不在先头部队里。好吧，好吧。尽管如此，她确实带了一架三角钢琴。好吧。我想这就像带一部iphone之类的东西，不是吗？嗯，无论怎样，他们说他们有——他们有——他们有，你知道的，260头骆驼的装备，50——30头骆驼运送雪茄，但他们没有地图。他们事后才试图买——从为阿瓦塔·贝尔（Avatar Bale）工作的法国拿破仑将军那里买——我想是在阿瓦塔·贝尔里，
Willie, why is Lady Sail going? They have the odicoloneologne, they have the shoes. The one thing they don't have is a mat. Right. Why is she going? Tom, that's a good question. Why does Lady Sail go and why does she take... I mean, that's mad to take.
其中一位拿破仑将军，把他在从法国的旅程中制作的阿富汗草图笔记和草图卖给了他们。东印度公司支付了惊人的费用，我想大概是25,000英镑，在1842年这大致相当于数百万英镑，买下这些由一个没有测量设备的家伙在马背上完成的草图。所以他们非常迷茫。有很多，你知道的，阿富汗在哪边？以及没有水供应的印度士兵的大规模死亡，巨大的伤亡。但违背所有常理，他们到达了沙漠的另一边，坎大哈的山脉另一边。
That's just deluded to take a piano with you. Well, you have to ask Lady Sail. But she's going along just for the fun of it. She takes the grand piano because she wants to play it. Lady Sail is going for the fun of it, for the fun of it. She takes the grand piano because she wants to play it. Lady Sale is going for the fun of it, for the excitement of it. No, no, she's married to Fighting Bob Sale, who is the... OK, right, right. So she's a military wife.
他们在同一天晚上攻占了坎大哈，尽管他们没有炮兵，因为他们把它们落在了后面。从这一点开始的进军就像本周的塔利班一样。每个人都跑了，丢下一切。他们不费一枪一弹就占领了喀布尔。这是一个直接的平行事件，这在阿富汗一遍又一遍地发生。阿富汗人不喜欢打阵地战，他们太善良了，不会那样做。他们让你占领他们的城市，然后
So there's not... I think, actually, in fairness, Lady Sale follows several months later. She's not actually on the advance guard. OK, OK. Nonetheless, she does bring a grand piano. OK. I suppose it's like taking an iphone or something isn't it um anyway they say they have they have they have you know 260 camels of kit uh 50 uh 30 camels carrying shrews but they don't have a map and they belatedly uh try and buy um off the french napoleonic general working for and it's in a vehicle uh i think avatar bel Avatar Bale, one of the Napoleonic generals,
这一切都从游击活动开始，这正是所发生的事情。但在一个冬天，英国人在喀布尔进行了业余戏剧表演，他们去打野鸭和滑冰，他们还打板球，不是吗？他们打板球。有很多板球。还有很多猎狐犬的狩猎活动。在行军中幸存下来的猎狐犬被带出去猎胡狼。而且大概那架钢琴在那里非常有用。与此同时，负责此事的人，一个名叫麦克诺顿（Mac Norton）的家伙，
sells them his sketch notes and sketch maps of Afghanistan that he's made on his journey from France. And the Eastern Company pays something colossal, like I think £25,000, which in 1842 is more or less like sort of a million pounds for these sketch maps done on horseback by a guy without surveying equipment. And so they get very lost. And there's a lot of, you know, which way is Afghanistan? And massive death of sepoys who haven't been given any water, massive casualties. But against all likelihood, they arrive the other side of the desert, another side of the mountains at Kandahar.
他是一位东方学者，在某个时刻，当然，他进入喀布尔时骑在大象背上，用阿拉伯语翻译《一千零一夜》。而戴着蓝边眼镜的麦克诺顿，也像其他人一样，讨厌亚历山大·伯恩斯。所以伯恩斯无事可做，完全被边缘化了。他举办了一个伯恩斯之夜。他是亚历山大·伯恩斯的表弟，伯恩斯无事可做，完全被边缘化了。他举办了一个伯恩斯之夜。他是亚历山大·伯恩斯的表弟，也是罗伯特·伯恩斯的表弟，虽然他的名字拼写略有不同。喀布尔有苏格兰圆舞曲和羊肚杂碎布丁（haggises）。但无所事事的
And they take Kandahar the same night, although they haven't got artillery because they've left them behind. And the march from this point is exactly like the Taliban this week. Everyone just runs off and leaves. And they take Kabul without firing a shot. It's a direct parallel and this happens over and over again in Afghanistan the Afghans do not like to fight pitch battles uh they're much too kind for that they let you take their cities and then
他又回到了老本行，开始勾引阿富汗军阀的妻子们。当然，如果你身处阿富汗，这是一件非常糟糕的事情，千万不要和任何军阀的妻子睡觉。而这正是促成叛乱的原因。他夺走了某个部落领袖阿卜杜拉·汗·阿查克扎伊（Abdullah Khan al-Chakzai）的情妇。根据我的朋友布鲁斯·万内尔（Bruce Wannell）为我翻译的一首阿富汗史诗中的一段，其中有一段是阿卜杜拉·汗·阿查克扎伊召集他的部族并说，英国人
it all begins with guerrilla activity and this is exactly what happened but one winter the British do amateur theatricals in Kabul uh they go duck shooting and ice skating and they play cricket don't they they They play cricket. There's lots of cricket. And there's lots of hunting of the foxhounds. Foxhounds who've survived the march are taken out to hunt jackals. And presumably the piano comes in very useful over there. In the meantime, the man put in charge of this, a guy called Mac Norton,
已经把他们欲望的毛驴骑进了愚蠢的田野。这可能是我整本书中最喜欢的一句话。我们都必须避免把我们欲望的毛驴骑进愚蠢的田野。好吧，我认为，我认为这是一个完美的音符，可以借此快速休息一下。现在，把愚蠢的毛驴骑进了田野或诸如此类的地方，我们将休息一下，当我们回来时，我们将把愚蠢的毛驴骑得更远，直到最终的灾难。
who is an orientalist who goes, at one point, certainly, he's on the top of an elephant as he's entering Kabul, translating the Arabian Nights from Arabic. And Mac Norton, who has blue-tinted spectacles, also, like everybody else, hates Alexander Burns. So Burns has got nothing to do, totally sidelined. He holds a Burns night. He is a cousin of Alexander Burns, and Burns got nothing to do, totally sidelined. He holds a Burns night. He is a cousin of Alexander Burns and he's a cousin of Robbie Burns, although his name is spelled slightly differently. And there's reels and there's haggises in Kabul. But with nothing
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的 rest is history》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目，
better to do, he gets back again and he starts seducing the wives of the Afghan warlords. And this, of course, is a very bad thing to do if you are in Afghanistan, do not sleep with any warlords' wives. And this is literally what precipitates the rebellion. He takes the mistress of one of the tribal leaders called Abdullah Khan al-Chakzai. And according to one of the Afghan epic poems, which my friend Bruce Wannell translated to me about this, there's a passage where Abdullah Khan Achaikzai summons his tribesmen and says, the English
以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。从克利奥帕特拉到卡米拉·帕克·鲍尔斯，从蓬巴杜夫人到洛拉·蒙特斯，另一个女人一直是整个历史上八卦的主食。但谁能进入我们历代十大情妇的名单呢？其中一些以美貌闻名，一些以政治谋略闻名，还有一些以卖橙子的本领闻名。
have ridden the donkey of their desires into the field of stupidity. This is possibly my favorite line in the whole book. We must all avoid riding the donkey of our desires into fields of stupidity well i think i think that's a perfect note on which to quickly take a break and now having ridden the donkey of stupidity into the field or whatever it is um we'll have a break and when we come back we will ride the donkey of stupidity even further to ultimate disaster.
迷人、精致、聪明、老练。加入我们，共度一个充满所有这些品质及更多内容的夜晚。多米尼克和我本人将于9月10日星期五晚上7点在伦敦播客节上出席“历史的 rest is history”现场活动。门票售价12.50英镑，可以在 kingsplace.co.uk 购买。kingsplace.co.uk。到时见。欢迎回到《历史的 rest is history》。我们一直在把欲望的毛驴骑进愚蠢的田野。接下来会发生什么？我预见前方有灾难。威利·达尔林普尔，我说的对吗？你完全正确，多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。这正是发生的事情。所以阿富汗部落奋起反抗，相当多的部落原本很高兴支持沙阿·苏贾，很高兴看到他回来，但他们没有一个人
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
喜欢这支英国占领军。东印度公司的军队表现得就像他们在孟加拉所做的那样。他们在喀布尔郊外的平原上，首先搭起帐篷，然后帐篷被木结构、接着是几座砖结构或石头结构所取代，就好像那是孟加拉的平原一样。显然，他们忽略了这样一个事实，即所有这些帐篷都被紧邻头顶的山脉俯瞰，是绝佳的狙击手地带。他们太忙于猎狐、跳苏格兰圆舞曲和做其他所有事情了。因此，当起义爆发时，叛乱分子很快就偷走了东印度公司的一些
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. From Cleopatra to Camilla Parker Bowles, and from Madame de Pompadour to Lola Montes, the other woman has been a staple of gossip throughout history. But who will make our list of the top ten mistresses of all time? Some of them are famed for their beauty, some for their political acumen, and some for their prowess in selling oranges.
大农炮，把它拉到营地周围的山丘上，开始轰炸营地。这是一个完全无法防守的位置。然后，正如命运安排的那样，因为这次起义并不是特别有计划的，它是由于阿卜杜拉·汗·阿查克扎伊的地下情女朋友跑到了亚历山大·伯恩斯的房子里而由阿卜杜拉·汗·阿查克扎伊发起的，冬天——第一个冬天的雪开始落下，山口被封锁了，显然没有来自加尔各答或旁遮普的援助。只有一个简单的问题
Glamour, sophistication, intelligence, savoir-faire. Join us for an evening rich in all these qualities and more. Dominic and myself will be at the Rest Is History Live at the London Podcast Festival, Friday, September 10th at 7pm. Tickets cost £12.50 and can be bought at kingsplace.co.uk. Kingsplace.co.uk. See you there. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We have been riding the donkey of desire into the fields of stupidity. And what's going to happen next? I foresee disaster ahead. William Dalrymple, am I right? You are exactly right, Dominic Thabrook. That is exactly what happened. So the Afghan tribes rise up and quite a lot of the tribes had been very happy to support Shah Shujan, were pleased to see him back, but none of them
关于军队的，威利，我想到了。你把它们描述为东印度公司的加农炮。所以这绝对是东印度公司的远征，而不是英国的国家远征吗？当我们谈到无政府状态时，特别是像我上次来节目时提到的普拉西战役（Plassey），这是一个非常非黑即白的事情，因为公司拥有20万印度土兵（sepoids），
like this British occupation force. And the East India Company army has behaved as it would have done in Bengal. They've laid out, first of all, their tents, then afterwards the tents are replaced by wooden and then a few brick structures or stone structures on the plains outside Kabul, as if it was the plains of Bengal. Apparently, omitting to notice that every single one of these these tents is overlooked by mountains immediately on top and perfect sniper territory. And they're too busy fox hunting and doing Scots reels and all the rest of it. So that when the uprising breaks out, very quickly the insurgents steal some East India Company
就像这支英国占领军一样。东印度公司的军队表现得就像他们在孟加拉时一样。他们首先搭起帐篷，后来帐篷被木结构取代，接着在喀布尔郊外的平原上又出现了一些砖石建筑，就好像这里是孟加拉平原一样。显然，他们忽略了一个事实：这些帐篷全都在紧邻上方的群山俯视之下，是绝佳的狙击阵地。他们忙着猎狐、跳苏格兰圆舞曲以及进行所有这些活动。因此，当起义爆发时，叛军非常迅速地夺取了一些东印度公司的
cannon, pull it onto the hills around the camp and start bombarding it. And it's a completely indefensible position. And then, as chance would have it, because this uprising was not particularly planned, it was started by Abdul Khandullah khan atchak's eye because uh his girlfriend had run off to alexander burns's house um winter uh the first winter snows begin to fall the passes block up and there's clearly no help coming from calcutta or from the punjab just a quick question
大炮，将其拉到营地周围的山丘上并开始轰炸。这是一个完全无法防守的位置。然后，由于机缘巧合，这场起义并不是特别有计划的，它是由阿卜杜勒·坎杜拉·汗·阿奇克扎伊（Abdul Khandullah khan atchak）挑起的，因为他的女朋友跑到了亚历山大·伯恩斯的家里。第一场冬雪开始降落，山口被封锁，显然没有任何来自加尔各答或旁遮普的援助。这里有一个简单的问题
about the army uh will, that occurs to me. You describe them as East India Company cannon. So is this definitely an East India Company expedition rather than a British national expedition? So when we were talking about the anarchy, and particularly battles like Plassey on the last time I came to the show, it's a very black and white thing because the company had 200,000 sepoids,
关于军队的，威尔，我想到了这一点。你将它们描述为东印度公司的大炮。所以这绝对是一次东印度公司的远征，而不是英国国家远征吗？因此，当我们上次我来节目时讨论无政府状态，特别是普拉西战役这样的战役时，这是一个非常黑白分明的事情，因为公司拥有20万名西帕依，
which were the force which invaded the whole of India. But in this case, there are now a mixture of regiments of the line, in other words, regular British army, fighting alongside East India Company sepoids. So the great mass of troops are East India Company sepoids, but I think there are at least two regiments of regular British Army so this is reflecting the position of the East India Company which by the 1840s has become much more
它们是入侵整个印度的军队。但在这种情况下，现在混合了正规军团，换句话说，就是正规英军，与东印度公司的西帕依并肩作战。因此，绝大多数军队都是东印度公司的西帕依，但我认为至少有两个正规英军团。所以这反映了东印度公司的地位，到19世纪40年代，它已经变得更像
of what I suppose today we would call a public-private punch what started off as the ultimate libertarian trading company with no government links at all, other than a charter to start it, has now become 50% owned by the British government
我们今天所说的公私合营。最初作为终极的自由主义贸易公司，除了成立特许状之外与政府没有任何联系，现在已经有50%由英国政府所有，
and by 1840 has actually been forbidden to, has lost its monopoly on trade. And so it's looking much more like a semi-governmental organization than the early days of Clive and Hastings. Right. But still, the fact remains, almost all the troops are Indian sepoys born in India. There's some Nepalese and some Gurkhas.
并且到1840年实际上已被禁止，失去了贸易垄断权。因此，它看起来越来越像一个半政府组织，而不像克莱夫和黑斯ティング斯（Hastings）的早期那样。对。但事实仍然是，几乎所有的军队都是在印度出生的印度西帕依。还有一些尼泊尔人和廓尔喀人。
And then there's a regiment of Skinner's Horse, for example, which is led by Anglo-Indians, the Skinner family. But there are several regiments in the line. And there's a snobbery of hierarchy. And the regiments in the line of British Army consider themselves superior to the East India Company. The East India Company, however, speak Urdu and Hindi and feel that they're much superior to British Army
比如说，还有斯金纳骑兵团（Skinner's Horse），由盎格鲁-印度人斯金纳家族领导。但正规军中还有好几个团。而且这里面存在着阶层傲慢。英国陆军正规军的团觉得他们比东印度公司更高级。然而，东印度公司的人会说乌尔都语和印地语，觉得自己比英国陆军优越得多
who don't know what's going on locally. So there's lots of rivalry going on. And that is reflected in the response to the uprising because the Elphinstone, William Elphinstone, who is the very dim cousin of the brilliant Mount Stewart Elphinstone, who is a gouty veteran of Waterloo
英国陆军对当地发生的事情一无所知。所以这里面有很多竞争。这也在对起义的反应中反映了出来，因为埃尔芬斯通——威廉·埃尔芬斯通（William Elphinstone），他是才华横溢的毛恩·斯图尔特·埃尔芬斯通（Mount Stewart Elphinstone）那个非常平庸的堂弟，是个患有痛风的滑铁卢老兵
who hasn't seen action since 1815. We're now talking 1842, January. And his deputy, who's a man called Shelton, and he are on non-speaks, they are massive divisions, and it's a complete fiasco. Not only are the company defeated in battle on
他自1815年以来就没再参战。我们现在说的是1842年1月。他的副手是一个叫谢尔顿（Shelton）的人，他们两个形同陌路，存在巨大的分歧，这是一场彻头彻尾的惨败。公司不仅在战斗中屡次战败
a few occasions, they do ride out and try and take on the insurgents in the hills around the country. They are running out of food. Lady Sale has now had to burn her grand piano for firewood because they've run out of eating material um they've eaten the foxhounds by the stage oh that's very bad form but the cricket bats are all right please tell me the cricket bats are okay i i think the cricket
他们有时会骑马出城，试图对付乡村山里的小股反叛武装。他们的食物快吃完了。塞尔夫人现在不得不烧掉她的三角钢琴来当柴火，因为他们连吃的东西都没了，嗯，他们甚至在这个阶段把猎狐犬都吃掉了，噢，这举止太糟糕了，不过板球拍还没事，请告诉我板球拍没事吧，我觉得板球
bats i suspect would also have been uh also but you know things are getting bad. Firm primary source evidence for that. Anyway, there's obviously no option but to retreat. And it's now January 1842. And the Afghans seem to be dragging their feet a little during negotiations. And people are mystified
拍我猜大概也已经……不过你知道情况正在恶化。有确凿的一手资料证据证明这一点。总之，显然除了撤退别无选择。现在已经是1842年1月。阿富汗人在谈判期间似乎有点拖拖拉拉。人们对此感到迷惑不解
by this because they think they probably want to get rid of us as much as we want to get out of here. And it drags on for two or three weeks. Finally, the moment comes in January when they set off into the snow. And everyone knows this is not looking good. The passes are anyway almost entirely blocked. No one
因为他们觉得阿富汗人可能跟我们一样急着想让我们滚蛋。谈判拖了两三个星期。终于，到了1月的那一天，他们踏入了风雪之中。所有人都知道这情况不妙。无论如何，山口几乎完全被堵死了。没有人
moves armies around Central Asia in the middle of winter because you can freeze in seconds outside your tent. And what of course has happened is the Afghans prepared a whole series of barricades and ambushes, and they're just waiting for them. And within a few hours of setting off from the cantum, not only have attacks begun on the column, but the cantum has been burnt down and looted, rather like some of the scenes seen in Kabul this weekend of looting.
会在严冬把军队调动到中亚，因为你在帐篷外几秒钟就会冻僵。当然，实际情况是阿富汗人设置了一系列路障和伏击，正等着他们呢。从坎顿门（cantonment）出发后短短几个小时内，不仅针对纵队的袭击开始了，而且坎顿门本身也被烧毁并洗劫一空，就像这个周末在喀布尔看到的那些掠夺场景一样。
The people run, oh no, exactly what happened to Bamiyan when he was deserted a month ago. Exactly what happened at Bagram Air Base when the Americans left it two months ago. The locals just ran in and looted it. It's exactly what happens in the British cantoomment in January 1842. So the first night, the British are stuck in the snow, having snipers firing at them, and they can see behind them the flames of the cantoomment, the light, the cantoomment, flickering fires, and they know there's no retreat, they can't go back, but it's five days
人们四处逃窜，哦不，这跟一个月前巴米扬被弃置时的情景一模一样。这跟两个月前美军撤离巴格拉姆空军基地时的情景一模一样。当地人蜂拥而入进行洗劫。这正是1842年1月英国军营里发生的事。所以在第一晚，英军被困在雪地里，遭到狙击手射击，他们能看到身后军营的烈火，军营的火光在闪烁，他们知道已经没有退路了，他们回不去了，但到
march to Jalanabad. And what I remember from Flashman is that Elphinstone gets shot in the buttocks, doesn't he? Well, that's so much with Flashman. There's an awful lot which is historically accurate but a certain amount of license... Right, okay, so that didn't happen. That's terrible. The one fact I remember isn't true.
贾拉拉巴德还有五天的路程。我从《弗莱士曼》（Flashman）里记得的是，埃尔芬斯通屁股中枪了，对吧？嗯，《弗莱士曼》里确实有这回事。里面有大量历史准确的内容，但也有一定程度的艺术加工……好吧，也就是说这并没有发生。太糟糕了。我记住的唯一一个事实居然不是真的。
Elphinstone is definitely wounded but in the sources I've read, buttocks are not. Okay. Explicitly. But yes, Elphi Bay, as he's called, is wounded, has a stroke, I think, probably in the middle of all this horror. And day by day, the number of survivors goes down from 20,000 to 10,000 to 5,000 to 2,000
埃尔芬斯通确实受伤了，但在我读过的史料里，没有明说屁股受伤。好吧。明确指出。不过是的，人们叫他“埃尔菲·贝”（Elphi Bay）的这家伙受伤了，我想在所有这些恐怖事件中他可能还中风了。日复一日，幸存者的数量从2万锐减到1万、5千、2千
there's a terrible moment at a place called Jigdalik where the holly hedge is erected in their path and the cavalry so far have been marching out fairly easily, can't get over this and they're shot down and people are crawling over it
在一个叫吉格达利克（Jigdalik）的地方发生了一个可怕的时刻，他们的路上筑起了一道冬青树篱，至今为止行军还算顺利的骑兵无法跨越这道树篱，他们被开枪击倒，人们在上面艰难地爬行
and several hundred die on this hedge, unable to cross this barrier that's erected in their way. And finally, there's a bunch of lancers making the last stretch, and the 51st Foot, who form themselves into a square on the hill of Gundamuk, fight until their ammunition is exhausted,
几百人死在这道树篱上，无法跨越挡在他们面前的这道屏障。最后，有一群枪骑兵在做最后的冲刺，第51步兵团（51st Foot）在刚达马克（Gundamuk）的山丘上结成方阵，他们战斗到弹药耗尽，
and then form a bayonet line. There's a very famous painting of this, isn't there, Willie? Famous painting, exactly. And they fight until their last bullet. They form a bayonet wall. But the Afghans realise there's no need to charge bayonets. They just pull back. And one of the features of the war is that the Afghans have this very old-fashioned mughal jazail which is a a hunting
然后组成刺刀阵。有一幅非常著名的关于这的画，对吧，威利？非常著名的画，确切地说。他们战斗到最后一颗子弹。他们筑起一道刺刀墙。但阿富汗人意识到根本不需要进行刺刀冲锋。他们只是撤退。这场战争的一个特点是，阿富汗人拥有这种非常老式的莫卧儿“杰宰尔”（mughal jazail）火枪，这是一种
rifle that shah jahan could be seen using to hunt deer and it's a big heavy unwieldy thing but it's it has a very long barrel and is accurate over a distance of about half a mile while the brown best musket fires only 300 yards so they realize there there's no need to take these guys on shoulder to shoulder. They just pull back and shoot from a distance. And every last man is killed, except for one guy who has wrapped himself in the colours. And he's taken hostage because they think he must be worth something because he's got such fancy coloured clothes on. And that is a guy called Thomas Souter. And the first British camp in Helmand was called Camp Souter after his memory.
沙贾汉（Shah Jahan）打猎时会用到的猎枪，那是一个又大又重、笨拙的物件，但它枪管很长，在半英里左右的距离内都很精准，而“布朗·贝斯”（Brown Bess）滑膛枪只能射击300码，所以他们意识到根本不需要跟这些家伙短兵相接。他们只要后退并在远处射击就行了。最后一个人都被杀死了，除了一个用军旗把自己裹起来的家伙。他被抓作人质，因为他们觉得他穿着这么华丽颜色的衣服，肯定很有价值。那个家伙叫托马斯·苏特（Thomas Souter）。赫尔曼德省的第一个英国军营为了纪念他，被称为“苏特营”（Camp Souter）。
Anyway, this leaves some Lancers who are cut down one by one by the last of the cavalry until only Dr. Brydon is left on his nag. And the reason Dr. Brydon survives is he has a copy of Blackwoods magazine. He's a reader. He would definitely have subscribed to The Rest is History if he was around today. He has a copy of Blackwoods magazine in his forage cap, so that when these two
总之，这留下了几名骑兵，被骑兵的残余力量一个接一个地砍倒，直到只剩下布赖登医生（Dr. Brydon）骑着他的瘦马。布赖登医生能活下来的原因是他带了一本《布莱克斯伍德杂志》（Blackwoods magazine）。他是个爱读书的人。如果他活在今天，他绝对会订阅《历史的剩余部分》（The Rest is History）。他的军帽里塞着一本《布莱克斯伍德杂志》，所以当这两个
Afghan horsemen come, one of them shoots a pistol which misfires, and then he hacks at him with a sword, but it goes into Blackwood's magazine, which is sitting in his hat because he seemingly wanted to read in the evening and doesn't pierce his skull.
阿富汗骑兵冲过来时，其中一人开枪却哑火了，然后他用剑向他砍去，但剑砍进了放在帽子里的《布莱克斯伍德杂志》里——显然他晚上想看书——并没有刺穿他的头骨。
And he alone of the British troops makes it through to Jalalabad. Did Blackwood's use that as a kind of advertising slogan? Should have done. Read Blackwoods, it'll keep you alive. It's the kind of thing the TLS would do, or London Review of Books or something. Contrary to the myth, he's not
他是英国军队中唯一一个成功抵达贾拉拉巴德的人。《布莱克斯伍德杂志》曾把这当作一种广告标语吗？本该这样的。读《布莱克斯伍德》，它能保你一命。这就像《泰晤士报文学增刊》（TLS）或者《伦敦书评》（London Review of Books）会做的那种事。与神话相反，他并不是
the only survivor, he's not even the only white survivor, several other troops straggle in after him. Bizarrely, a Greek shopkeeper who'd been running this sort of kebab shop at the cantonment has hidden in a cave and comes in with a bottle of uzu a week later. And there's a whole bunch of Nepali Gurkhas
唯一的幸存者，他甚至不是唯一的白人幸存者，在他之后还有好几支部队零零散散地走了进来。离奇的是，一个在军营里经营某种烤肉店的希腊店主躲在一个山洞里，一周后带着一瓶乌佐酒（uzu）走了进来。还有一大群尼泊尔廓尔喀人
who have just gone up some valleys and are completely happy with the temperature and are completely used to surviving. And so the Gurkhas sort of reappear about a week later in perfect order with their medal shining and all the rest of it. And then some of the Hindu sepoys turn up a year and a half later at the Kumella in Hardwa, having walked all the way home. So he's not, in fact, the only survivor.
他们只是走进了某些山谷，对那里的温度感到完全适应，并且完全习惯了在恶劣环境中生存。所以廓尔喀人大约一周后以完美的队列再次出现，勋章闪闪发光，诸如此类。然后一些印度教土兵（sepoys）在一年半后出现在赫尔德瓦尔（Hardwar）的库梅拉（Kumella），他们是一路走回家的。所以他事实上并不是唯一的幸存者。
So two people, what their fate is. So Lady Sale. Lady Sale, along with all the other ladies, or several of the other ladies, not all of them, many are killed. But Lady Sale, along with several others, have taken hostage. And then there's protracted hostage negotiations.
那么两个人，他们的命运如何呢。萨尔夫人（Lady Sale）。萨尔夫人和其他所有的女士一起，或者说几位其他女士，并非全部，许多人被杀了。但萨尔夫人和其他几个人一起被当作人质抓走了。然后是漫长的人质谈判。
And basically, at the end of the day, there's a swap. Dost Muhammad, who had been captured, or rather given himself up, had been kept in the British hill station of Missouri in the Himalayas. Dost Muhammad is brought back. And the man negotiating is Dost Muhammad's son, Akbar Khan,
归根结底，最后进行了一场交换。之前被俘、或者说主动投降的多斯特·穆罕默德（Dost Muhammad），一直被关押在喜马拉雅山脉的英国山地疗养胜地穆索里（Mussoorie）。多斯特·穆罕默德被带了回来。负责谈判的人是多斯特·穆罕默德的儿子阿克巴·汗（Akbar Khan），
who is a young, handsome sort of movie hero type who's led this resistance and planned the holly hedge at Djigdalik and all the rest. And Joss Muhammad is brought home. He makes an agreement with the British that he will not allow the Russians in. And otherwise, he's allowed to come back unmolested.
他是一个年轻、英俊、有点像电影英雄似的人物，领导了这次抵抗，并策划了吉格达利克的冬青树篱等等。多斯特·穆罕默德被带回了家。他与英国人达成协议，不让俄国人进来。除此之外，他被允许不受骚扰地回来。
And you end up, and Lady Sale and the others are swapped for him. And they haven't been molested. There are several other they've been looked after well have they or have they fared in captivity very well including my direct forebear uh colin mckenzie who's one who's dressed up in afghan dress making a great sort of uh he has lots of self-portraits painted when government, which was in power before all this, coming back into power.
结果就是，萨尔夫人和其他人被用来交换他。而且他们没有受到骚扰。还有几个其他人，他们被照顾得很好吗？他们在囚禁中过得怎么样？包括我的直系祖先科林·麦肯齐（Colin Mackenzie），他是那些穿上阿富汗服饰、大显身手的人之一，他有很多自画像……当在这一切之前掌权的政府重新掌权时。
And because no one can threaten it anymore because of the enormous prestige it's won, defeating imperial power, Dost Muhammad then stays in power for the rest of his life and he has a very grand tomb which i've seen in the ghazagar in herat one of the most beautiful sufi shrines uh in afghanistan and and willie what what about um shah shuja so shah shuja who's the hero of my book return of a king the king in question question is Shah Shuja. Shah Shuja is a very attractive character. He is a poet. He keeps his nerve when the uprising breaks out in Kabul and when the British flee and desert him.
而且由于没有人能再威胁到它，因为它通过击败帝国力量赢得了巨大的声望，多斯特·穆罕默德随后在余生中一直掌权，他有一座非常宏伟的陵墓，我在赫拉特的加扎加尔（Ghazagar）见过，那是阿富汗最美丽的苏菲圣地之一。威利，那沙·舒贾（Shah Shuja）呢？所以沙·舒贾——我书中的主角《一个国王的归来》（Return of a King）中的那个国王就是沙·舒贾。沙·舒贾是一个非常有吸引力的人物。他是一个诗人。当喀布尔爆发起义、英国人逃跑并抛弃他时，他保持了镇定。
He's holed up in the Balahisar, having defended it very admirably. He's an extremely brave man. His flaw is he's too grand. having defended it very admirably. He's an extremely brave man. He's persistent. His flaw is he's too grand. He makes everybody stand in his dhurbars, which was the Mughal style, and his mother is Mughal, but it's not the manner the Afghans used to. They're used to sitting down on the carpet
他在巴拉希萨尔（Balahisar）坚守，防守得非常出色。他是一个极其勇敢的人。他的缺点是架子太大。防守得非常出色。他是一个极其勇敢的人。他很有毅力。他的缺点是架子太大。他让所有人在他的朝廷（dhurbars）里都站着，这是莫卧儿风格，他的母亲是莫卧儿人，但这并不是阿富汗人习惯的礼节。他们习惯了坐成一圈
all together in a tribal jirga. And this egalitarian mode is what makes Das Mohammed so successful. He doesn't playground. He entertains and charms all his tribesmen. And this is one of the many parallels, if we can move on to parallels, with the present.
大家一起坐在地毯上开部落吉尔加大会（jirga）。这种平等主义的方式正是多斯特·穆罕默德如此成功的原因。他没有架子。他招待并吸引了他所有的部落成员。如果我们接着谈论与当今的相似之处，这是众多相似之处之一。
But just before that, what happens to Shishuja? Shishuja survives all this. The British cut up, the deals are done, and Shah Shuja in the end is killed by a godson who wants to get in with Dos Mohamed. But for that, he may well have survived the whole thing uh but but he he has slighted a godson who feels he hasn't been given promotion or something and
但在那之前，沙·舒贾怎么样了？沙·舒贾在这一切中幸存了下来。英国人撤离，交易达成，沙·舒贾最终被一个想要巴结多斯特·穆罕默德的教子杀害。若非如此，他很可能会在整场事件中幸存下来……但但他轻视了一个教子，后者觉得自己没有得到晋升之类的
so there's a small petty internal feud does so it's it's rudeness that does it and sorry i interrupted you when you were talking about the parallels because that is a great parallel isn't it because um there is a huge premium in Afghanistan still on basic climate. And this was one of the great qualities of Hamid Karzai, who would make every Afghan, particularly any tribal elder, who'd come in from the countryside, he would give them time, he would talk to them, he would... So he was the first president of...
所以这是一场微不足道的内部小恩怨，是无礼举动导致了这一切。抱歉，刚才你谈论相似之处时我打断了你，因为这确实是个很好的相似之处，对吧？因为在阿富汗，基本的气候……哦不，是基本的人际礼节依然备受重视。这也是哈米德·卡尔扎伊（Hamid Karzai）的一大优秀品质，他会给每个阿富汗人时间，特别是那些从乡下来到这里的部落长老，他会跟他们谈话，他会……所以他是……的第一任总统。
He was the first president of the United States. Scored in what, 2002? In 2002. But the important point, as far as, again, this war is concerned, that we're talking about, is he is the direct descendant of Shah Shuja. He is the head of the Pupulzai tribe. We basically put the same guy in twice. Karzai is a slightly nicer version of Shah Shuja.
他是……的第一任总统。是在什么，2002年？在2002年。但就我们正在讨论的这场战争而言，重要的一点是，他是沙·舒贾的直系后代。他是普帕尔扎伊部落（Popuzai）的领袖。我们基本上把同一个人扶上台了两次。卡尔扎伊其实是沙·舒贾的一个稍微温和一点的版本。
And Karzai did actually an incredible job charming everyone. And his replacement, Ashraf Ghani, who incidentally is a good friend, was very kind to me, was the man that helped me find a lot of the sources for the book when he was head of the history department and chancellor of Kabul University. Ashraf was incredibly rude to people. was very grand he had worked for the World Bank taught at Columbia he didn't have time for fools he was a very successful university professor and World Bank technocrat
卡尔扎伊确实做了一件不可思议的工作，迷住了所有人。而他的继任者阿什拉夫·加尼（Ashraf Ghani）——顺便说一句，他是个好朋友，对我也很好——当他是喀布尔大学历史系主任兼校长时，正是他帮我找到了书中许多资料。阿什拉夫对人极其粗鲁。他架子很大，曾在世界银行工作，在哥伦比亚大学教书，他没有时间应付蠢货，他是一个非常成功的大学教授和世界银行技术官僚。
but would give tribal leaders who'd walked 20 days across Afghanistan to see him 10 minutes he'd literally say you've got 10 minutes another story I've heard which is interesting is that he also put his feet up in front of tribal elders. Now, in India still today, I've always been taught that you must never point your feet at someone. If you're sitting cross-legged, it's hugely rude in that culture to point your feet or to put your feet up.
但对于那些跋涉20天穿越阿富汗来见他的部落领袖，他只给10分钟，他会直截了当地说：“你们只有10分钟。”我听到的另一个有趣的故事是，他在部落长老面前居然把脚翘在桌上。直到今天在印度，我一直被教导说，你绝不能把脚尖指向别人。如果你盘腿坐着，在这种文化中把脚尖指向别人或把脚翘起来是极其无礼的。
Ashraf Ghani had a sort of poof in front of his armchair, and he to put your feet up. Ashraf Ghani had a sort of puff in front of his armchair and he just put his feet up like you would at home. But this went down apparently very badly and serially offended a whole series of tribal elders who invited him to his inner sanctum. And Karzai never did this. And a weird story with this is that Karzai read my book, Return of a King, and he had always been haunted
阿什拉夫·加尼的扶手椅前放着一个小圆凳，他把脚……他把脚翘了起来。阿什拉夫·加尼的扶手椅前放着一个矮脚凳，他就那么把脚翘起来了，就像你在家里做的那样。但这显然产生了非常糟糕的影响，连续冒犯了一系列被邀请进入他内阁的部落长老。卡尔扎伊从不这样做。关于这件事有一个离奇的故事，那就是卡尔扎伊读了我的书《一个国王的归来》，他一直被一个阴影笼罩
by the fact that Shalshuja was his forebear, and that Shalshuja had died regarded as a traitor by many of the Afghans. And he was particularly worried because the tribe which brought down Shalshuja,
那就是沙·舒贾是他的先祖，而沙·舒贾死时被许多阿富汗人视为叛徒。他特别担心，因为推翻沙·舒贾的那个部落……
who were the leaders of the guy who's, sorry, the tribesmen of the man whose mistress, Alexander Burns, seduced Abdullah Khan Achaikzade, were the Gilzai tribe. And so beneath what we perceive very easily today as a simple battle of Democrats and Westernized Afghans against Islamist tribal barbarians actually masks a old tribal fault line, is the Barakzais and Popozais, who are the landowners, against the Gilzai, who are the herdsmen and the day labourers on the Popozais land. And Mullah Omar is a descendant of the resistance leader of
抱歉，是那个人的部落成员，其情妇被亚历山大·伯恩斯（Alexander Burns）勾引的阿卜杜拉·汗·阿查伊克扎德（Abdullah Khan Achaikzade），他们是吉尔扎伊部落（Gilzai）。所以，在我们今天很容易看作是民主派和西方化阿富汗人对抗伊斯兰部落野蛮人的简单战斗背后，其实掩盖了一条古老的部落断层线——那是作为地主阶级的巴拉克扎伊（Barakzais）和普帕尔扎伊（Popuzais）对抗作为普帕尔扎伊土地上的牧民和日工的吉尔扎伊（Gilzai）。而毛拉·奥马尔（Mullah Omar）正是1842年抵抗运动领袖的后代。
1842. So, Willie, the implication of all that well, that would for some listeners, they will say that that creates a sense of inevitability, that the patterns of history are merely repeating themselves. Is that too simplistic, though? Or do you think there is a kind of truth to that?
所以，威利，所有这一切的含义是……好吧，这会让某些听众说，这营造了一种不可避免的感觉，即历史的模式只是在重蹈覆辙。但这是否过于简单化了呢？或者你认为其中确实某种程度上存在着真相？
In this case, we did literally put the same guy on the throne twice. We put the head of the Popozai tribe, and he was brought down by the Gilzai. Was that simple? And let's say the weird story that follows is that Karzai read Return of the King very closely. He was given it by someone as he was on his way to Washington to meet Obama. And none of us knew any about this until WikiLeaks, because it turned out that Hillary Clinton was very upset, because when he came out of the place, having read this book, he altered his policy and began to be publicly much more hostile to the americans while taking their help while taking their military he saw it as vital that he didn't look like shah suja and appear to be the puppet of the americans and so publicly started making very rude remarks about americans you know creating casualties by uh inadequate
在这种情况下，我们确实字面意义上把同一个人两次扶上了王位。我们把普帕尔扎伊部落的领袖扶上台，而他被吉尔扎伊人推翻了。这简单吗？接下来发生的一件离奇的事是，卡尔扎伊非常仔细地阅读了《一个国王的归来》。有人在他前往华盛顿会见奥巴马的途中把这本书送给了他。在我们通过“维解泄密”（WikiLeaks）得知此事之前，我们对此一无所知，因为事实证明希拉里·克林顿非常沮丧，因为当他读完这本书从房间里出来后，他改变了政策，开始在公开场合对美国人表现得更加敌视，同时又接受他们的帮助，接受他们的军事援助。他认为至关重要的一点是，自己不能看起来像沙·舒贾，不能表现得像是美国人的傀儡，因此开始公开发表对美国人非常粗鲁的言论，你知道的，比如由于情报不足、轰炸错误村庄等原因造成平民伤亡，诸如此类的事情。
intelligence bombing the wrong villages all this sort of stuff. And he was very frosty to Obama. And WikiLeaks revealed these letters, emails from Hillary Clinton, which were, we now know, taken by the Russians and handed to WikiLeaks. What is this bloody book that Karzai is reading? Ever since he picked it up he's become completely intransigent and won't talk to us and is incredibly rude and this was all on the on when wikileaks came out this is all on the front page of the new york
他对奥巴马非常冷淡。“维解泄密”披露了希拉里·克林顿的这些信件和电子邮件，我们现在知道，这些邮件被俄国人获取并交给了维解泄密。卡尔扎伊在读的这本该死的书到底是什么？自从他拿起这本书以来，他就变得完全冥顽不灵，不肯跟我们说话，而且极其粗鲁。当维解泄密事件爆发时，这一切都登上了《纽约时报》的头条
time uh and at this point i then got invited to um to to brief the book more and more but the best bit was when Khazai then called me to one Ramadan to his palace, now occupied by the Taliban. I saw a picture on the Internet this morning of the Taliban flag flying over the Ard, the the old citadel in the center of Kabul. But we basically did a deal. And Khazai said, if you come to me during Ramadan, which is the kind of big fasting and the holiday in the Islamic world, come to me during Ramadan and we will talk every evening after Iftar, after breaking the fast. We will have fruit together and I will ask you about shashuja and in return you can have an interview. So I got six hours of interview with Kaza, which went into a york times profile uh which is online if anyone wants to read it uh and in return kaza i got to ask all the questions about shashuja uh from these sources which ashraf ghani had given me so it's all it's a rare case of a history book in a small way genuinely uh altering uh the course of uh of policy day um in the end of, genuinely altering the course of policy.
就在这时，我被邀请去越来越多地为这本书做情况介绍，但最棒的部分是，后来卡尔扎伊在一个斋月把我叫到他的宫殿——现在那里被塔利班占领了。今天早上我在网上看到一张照片，塔利班的旗帜在阿尔格（Ard，喀布尔市中心的旧城堡）上空飘扬。但我们基本上达成了一笔交易。卡尔扎伊说，如果你在斋月期间来找我——斋月是伊斯兰世界盛大的斋戒和节日——在斋月期间来找我，我们每天晚上在伊夫塔尔（Iftar，开斋）之后一起谈话。我们一起吃水果，我会向你询问关于沙·舒贾的事，作为交换，你可以对进行采访。所以我获得了对卡尔扎伊长达六小时的采访，这篇采访登上了《纽约时报》的人物专栏，如果有人想读的话可以在网上找到。作为回报，卡尔扎伊得以从阿什拉夫·加尼给我的这些资料中提出所有关于沙·舒贾的问题。所以这是一个罕见的例子，一本历史书在某种微小的程度上，真正地改变了政策的走向……
In the end, of course, it didn't make any difference because, as we now know, the wider lineaments of history repeating overtook all this. And we're now back exactly where we were at the end of the 1842 First Anglo-Afghan War with the same ruler in charge. Well, that's the question, isn't it? Isn't it, Willie? Do you think, looking back now after 20 years, I mean, I know this is a massive question and we're reaching the end of the podcast anyway, but do you think the Taliban's victory was inevitable?
到头来，当然，这并没有什么区别，因为正如我们现在所知，历史重演的宏大轮廓压倒了这一切。我们现在又回到了1842年第一次英阿战争结束时的原点，由同一位统治者掌权。嗯，这就是问题所在，不是吗？难道不是吗，威利？你认为，现在回看过去的20年——我的意思是，我知道这是一个巨大的问题，而且我们的播客也快接近尾声了——你认为塔利班的胜利是不可避免的吗？
No, I don't think it was inevitable. I think Karzai showed that with the right politeness and kindness and by distancing himself from his Western host, he could mask the fact that he was kept in power by a Western puppet master and make a regime which was acceptable to the Afghan. But it was touch and go. And when someone less dexterous, Ashraf Ghani, took over and was rude to people and diminished the popularity of the regime and alienated one by one tribal leaders from across the country. Ashraf actually had a temper. He used to throw things at people. I heard a story, for example, one press conference where he threw an ashtray at a female journalist.
不，我不认为这是不可避免的。我认为卡尔扎伊表明，通过恰当的礼貌、友善以及与西方主子保持距离，他可以掩盖自己是被西方操纵者维持权力的事实，并建立一个阿富汗人能够接受的政权。但这确实千钧一发。而当一个没有那么圆滑的人——阿什拉夫·加尼——接权并对人粗鲁、降低了政权的受欢迎程度、并一个接一个地疏远了全国各地的部落领袖时。阿什拉夫其实脾气很暴躁。他过去常常向别人扔东西。例如，我听说过这样一个故事，在一次新闻发布会上，他向一名女记者扔了一个烟灰缸。
That sort of thing just doesn't play. Because really, I mean, the general sense that historians have is the interplay of great tectonic plates grinding against each other, vast impersonal forces. But in 1842, it's Burns seducing the wrong woman. And you're saying that now it's a guy throwing ashtrays at people. I think we know in our own time. Are those tiny kind of trigger points that affect? I think from our own experience in our own time, there are tiny things, these great forces of history, these great Tolstoyan moments, these great Tolstoyan forces which form the economy and shape the destiny of nations do exist. But equally, tiny little accidents can alter things. For example, in our own time, if Boris Johnson had had, you know, he famously wrote the two articles pro-Brexit and against Brexit. If he had actually decided to back camera and not taken the path of going for Brexit,
那种行为根本行不通。因为真的，我的意思是，历史学家普遍感受到的，是相互挤压的巨大构造板块、庞大的非人格力量。但在1842年，却是伯恩斯勾引了错误的女人。而你现在说的是一个向别人扔烟灰缸的家伙。我想我们在这个时代也深有体会。那些是影响历史的微小触发点吗？我认为从我们这个时代的经验来看，微小的事情是存在的，这些伟大的历史力量，这些伟大的托尔斯泰式时刻、形成经济并塑造民族命运的托尔斯泰式力量确实存在。但同样，微小的意外也能改变事情。例如，在我们这个时代，如果鲍里斯·约翰逊当时——众所周知，他写了两篇分别支持脱欧和反对脱欧的文章。如果他当时真的决定支持卡梅伦，而没有选择走脱欧这条路，
would we be where we are now with Europe? Quite possibly not. One man's decision at a crucial moment can alter things. In the context of Afghanistan, though, you say that this is a society where politeness is very important and knowing the rules of courtesy are very important do you think it's a problem and you know for the west right the way from from from the 1840s that we tend not to know these rules it certainly is a problem um and you know as as I said, there are a huge array of possibilities every day in all our lives. If we were to turn right rather than to turn left at a given moment, how history would be different. But, yes, I think I don't think that it was impossible that a pro-Western regime could have survived in Afghanistan because the Taliban
我们现在还会和欧洲处于同样的境地吗？很可能不会。关键时刻一个人的决定就能改变事情。不过，在阿富汗的背景下，你说这是一个礼貌非常重要、懂得礼节规则非常重要的社会，你认为这是一个问题吗——你知道，对西方来说，从1940年代一路走来——我们往往不懂这些规则？这当然是一个问题，而且正如我所说，在我们所有人的生活中，每天都有着大量的可能性。如果在特定的时刻我们向右转而不是向左转，历史会有多么不同。但是，是的，我认为一个亲西方政权在阿富汗生存下来并非不可能，因为塔利班
were very unpopular. They were an extremely brutal regime. This regime now, though, is regarded as incredibly corrupt. And it's rather like the Islamic revolution in Iran in the 70s. There is a huge number of people who feel that a small elite have gobbled up corruptly huge sums of money. There are stories circulating in Kabul now that Ashraf Ghani's car was stuffed with cash and they couldn't get it all in the plane he escaped in and a lot of the money was left on the
非常不受欢迎。他们是一个极其残暴的政权。不过，现在的这个政权被认为极其腐败。这有点像70年代伊朗的伊斯兰革命。有大量的人觉得一小撮精英腐败地吞噬了巨额资金。喀布尔现在流传着这样的故事：阿什拉夫·加尼的车里塞满了现金，他们根本没法把钱全塞进他逃跑时坐的那架飞机里，许多钱被留在了喀布尔的跑道上。
runway in Kabul. Three or four people have told me the story. I have no idea whether it's true or not. But the fact that enough people believe these stories creates an atmosphere where the regime that has just ended was seen to be corrupt, greedy.
有三四个人跟我讲过这个故事。我不知道它是真是假。但足够多的人相信这些故事，就会营造出一种氛围：刚刚倒台的这个政权被认为是腐败的、贪婪的。
Ghani's nephew left in a Learjet with an Instagram post saying, trying to leave as bad as I can. That sort of thing creates massive upset with poor people who have not got their hands in the money pot, who are not
加尼的侄子坐着里尔喷气机（Learjet）离开，并在Instagram上发帖称，正试图尽可能狼狈地离开。那种事情会在那些没有沾到钱、没有分到蜂蜜的穷人中引起巨大的愤慨。
eating the honey. And I think many people will be waiting to see whether this regime is better for them. Many women will have their lives destroyed. There will be huge cruelty. There will be terrible... I mean, I
我想很多人都在拭目以待，看这个政权是否会对他们更好。许多女性的生活将被毁掉。会有极大的残酷。会有可怕的……我的意思是，我
personally think it's a catastrophe. And I have many, many friends whose lives have been hobbled and restricted and whose lives may well be in danger. I got an email from Karzai's office this morning saying he's okay and that he's... It read rather like, in fact, a kind of carry on up the Kaiba email saying, there was some moments of tension, but all is now restored. Right, well, hope for the best. What a somber note on which to end. Incredible sang-froid.
个人认为这是一场灾难。我有很多很多朋友，他们的生活受到了阻碍和限制，他们的生活很可能正处于危险之中。我今天早上收到卡尔扎伊办公室发来的一封电子邮件，说他没事，而且他……读起来其实有点像那种滑稽电影《赶上开伯尔山口》（Carry On Up the Khyber）风格的邮件，上面写着：有过一些紧张时刻，但现在一切都恢复正常了。好吧，祝一切顺利吧。以多么忧郁的调子结尾啊。真是不可思议的冷静。
But many people's lives will be deeply damaged by this. Whether this regime manages to solidify itself and hold together like Das Mohammed managed after the catastrophe of 1842 when he came back into power remains to be seen. Already, certainly, the Taliban have proved to be far more disciplined and less fractured than we all thought they were. The idea was that this was a bunch of disparate hooligans and fundamentalists in the hills, incapable really of co-hearing and mounting a coordinated campaign. But that was clearly very wrong. It's been an extraordinary military success. So a bit like the way that the various tribes in 1842 got together to absolutely seal the doom of the British retreat. Exactly that. Although again, you know, there were all sorts of tensions
但许多人的生活将因此受到深重的损害。这个政权是否能像多斯特·穆罕默德在1842年灾难后重掌权力那样，设法巩固自身并凝聚在一起，还有待观察。当然，塔利班已经证明自己远比我们想象的更加纪律严明、裂痕更少。人们原本以为这是一群山地里乌合之众的暴徒和原教旨主义者，实际上没有能力凝聚在一起并发起协同战役。但这种想法显然大错特错。这是一次非凡的军事成功。所以有点像1842年各部落联合起来彻底注定英国军队撤退命运的方式。正是如此。尽管再次说明，抵抗内部其实也存在着各种各样的紧张关系
and tribal rivalries within the resistance. But they held together. Yeah. OK, well, that's an incredibly sombre note on which to end. And again, absolute tour de force
和部落竞争。但他们团结在一起了。好吧，这是一个极其忧郁的结尾调子。再次感谢你，这是一次精彩绝伦的历史阐述。
of historical explication. Yeah, thank you, Willie. Thank you. You retain your record. Yeah, you definitely retain your record. Could I, there's just one thing, one other note on which I'd like to end,
是的，谢谢你，威利。谢谢。你保持了你的纪录。是的，你绝对保持了你的纪录。我能……还有一件事，我想以此作为另一个结尾，
which is, it's not to do with Afghanistan, but it is to do with Iraq, where Western forces also intervened and left a kind of a lot of damage. And it's a walk that I'm doing on the 23rd and 24th. So that's next Monday, if you're listening to this, as it comes out. And next Tuesday, walking 50 miles in 24 hours. 23rd and 24th so that's uh next monday if you're listening to this as it comes out and next tuesday walking um 50 miles in 24 hours and that is partly in aid of yezidi refugees um
这与阿富汗无关，但与伊拉克有关，西方军队也在那里进行了干预并留下了大量的破坏。这是我将在23日和24日进行的一次徒步。所以那是下周一，如果你在节目刚发布时收听的话。下周二，在24小时内步行50英里。23日和24日，所以那是下周一，如果你在节目刚发布时收听的话，还有下周二，步行50英里，历时24小时，这部分是为了资助雅兹迪难民——
religious minority in iraq who still can't go back to their homes who are suffering terribly intense so any um any sponsorship you could give me on that would be hugely appreciated and you can get the link on my it's my pinned tweet at holland underscore tom so many thanks for that thank you willie for allowing me to do that thank you dominic another appeal at this point um rory stewart's turquoise mountain foundation has issued an appeal for afghans who are in difficulty at the moment in afghanistan rory stewart's um uh twitter site is easy to find there aren't any other rory stewart's um and at his pinned tweet at the top of his thing but a very very well yeah yeah thank you willie that was absolutely fascinating so that ends our afghan duo and
伊拉克的宗教少数群体，他们仍然无法重返家园，正遭受着极其深重的痛苦——所以你能对此提供的任何赞助都将不胜感激，你可以在我的置顶推文中找到链接，推特账号是@holland_underscore_tom。非常感谢，谢谢威利允许我这样做。谢谢多米尼克。此时还有另一个呼吁……罗里·斯图尔特（Rory Stewart）的“绿松石山基金会”（Turquoise Mountain Foundation）已经为目前在阿富汗处于困境中的阿富汗人发起了呼吁。罗里·斯图尔特的推特主页很容易找到，没有其他叫罗里·斯图尔特的人了，就在他主页顶部的置顶推文中。非常非常感谢，威利，这真的太引人入胜了。我们的阿富汗双人组节目就到这里，
we will see you all next week for more the Rest is History. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下周将为大家带来更多《历史的剩余部分》。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。